I was born and raised
in Caracas, Venezuela,
back in the '80s and '90s.
Venezuela is a beautiful country,
rich with natural treasures
from beaches to rainforests.
But one thing that people
don't quite realize
is that we also have
really tall mountains.
These are part of the Andes,
and they stretch all the way down
from Chile and Argentina.
And they're also home to some
of the very few tropical glaciers
in the world.
Back in 1910, when the first
map was drawn,
Venezuela used to have
five tropical glaciers,
which we used to call
the five white eagles.
Today, unfortunately,
there's only one left,
and it covers an area which is smaller
than Central Park in New York City.
These glaciers have been disappearing
because of the use of a resource
that we extract not too far from them:
oil.
As a Venezuelan, my relationship
with oil is complicated.
On the one hand, oil is the resource
that helped my country develop,
as well as human civilization.
On the other hand,
it's a resource that slowly but surely
fuels an existential threat.
Climate change.
We now know that to avert
the worst impacts of climate change,
we're going to have to decarbonize
everything that we do
and everything that surrounds us.
And to do that within
the next three decades.
These include things like
transitioning from oil, natural gas
to clean sources of electricity;
electrifying all of our vehicles;
rethinking the way that we make
our buildings and cities.
The good news is that technologies to do
some of these things already exist.
And legislation to frame
and direct this effort
is starting to be put in place.
The bad news is that even
if we do all of these things,
it will still not be enough.
There are still large sectors
of our economy
that will need to be decarbonized
for which we don't have
the technology yet.
These include the things like
manufacturing processes
that are used to make everything
that surrounds us,
from the cement and steel
that holds our buildings together
to the chemicals and materials
that we use to make the goods
that we use in our daily lives.
Things like the chair
that you're sitting in,
your shoes, the cars that you use,
and all the devices that we use every day.
The chemical manufacturing industry
alone accounts for 10 percent
of the energy consumption.
And 20 percent of the carbon
emissions from industry.
These emissions arise
from the use of fossil fuel combustion
to generate the heat that is required
to drive processes inside of our old
and inefficient chemical plants.
One way to start fixing the issue
will be to use electricity
instead of heat from fossil fuels
to drive the processes
inside of these plants.
Sounds easy enough, right?
Just unplug the natural gas pipelines,
plug in the electrical wire,
and make sure that you source electricity
from clean sources like solar,
wind or nuclear.
Unfortunately, in reality,
it's much harder than that.
We're going to have to come up
with new chemical reactions
that can source their energy
directly from electricity.
These are called
electrochemical reactions.
And it’s what my research group
at New York University is focusing on:
figuring out electrochemical paths
that can create direct links
between clean electricity and molecules.
In electrochemical reactions,
heat is replaced by electricity
as an energy source.
This allows us to operate reactors
and carry out reactions
at room temperature
with minimal energy losses.
But the problem is
that for electrochemical reactions
to become viable,
they will need to be more efficient
and cost competitive
than the heat-powered ones
that we use today.
That means that electrochemical reactors
will need to transform
raw materials into products
very efficiently, with minimal waste
and very selectively.
This will then in turn incentivize
chemical manufacturers
to switch to electrochemical
production processes
instead of deploying
new fossil fuel chemical plants.
In our research, we started
by looking at a chemical reaction
that is used to make one of the most
important polymers in the world:
Nylon 66.
More than 5 million tons
of all kinds of nylons
are produced every year.
And out of those, two million
tons are of Nylon 66.
And these are used to make things
like the textile fibers
that we use in our winter jackets
or the plastic car parts
that help make our vehicles
lightweight and fuel-efficient.
Through our research,
we managed to identify
electrochemical reaction mixtures
with the right additives and voltages
to be able to transform raw materials
into nylon precursors very selectively.
We achieved selectivity
of more than 80 percent,
a value that is on par
with commercial reactors.
But we didn't stop there.
While most electrochemical
reactions operate
with a constant stream
of electrical currents,
we knew that if we control
the interactions
between the electricity
input and molecules,
we could achieve a higher performance.
To do that, we decided to start exploring
different electrical pulses
in the search for the right pulse sequence
that will deliver electrons
at the same rate
that molecules could react.
Since there were so many pulses
that we needed to test,
we decided to then use
a few number of results
from different pulses to train
machine-learning models
that then help us identify
the appropriate pulse sequence
for this reaction.
This was the first time
that artificial intelligence was used
to optimize an electrochemical reaction,
and the pulse sequence that we discovered
allows us to increase by 30 percent
the production rate of these reactors.
These large improvements in efficiency,
selectivity and production rates
are very important
because they will ensure
that electrochemical reactions
are competitive
with fossil-fuel-powered ones
which are already highly optimized.
But hey, nylon is only one molecule
in a network of tens of thousands
of chemical products,
many of which you see in this diagram,
and many of which are a common
occurrence in your daily lives.
Just think of the plastics that are used
to make your computers and phones,
or the pane that covers
the walls around us,
or the medicines that help us
live a healthy life.
We're going to have to decarbonize it all
within the next 30 years.
That means that we're going
to have to discover,
develop and deploy
chemical processes much faster
than we did in the past century.
To that end, my group at NYU
is combining artificial intelligence
with autonomous research tools
to run hundreds to thousands
of experiments per day.
In this way, we hope to decrease
the time from idea to discovery
by more than 100 times.
Beyond nylon,
we're also looking
into production processes
to manufacture other chemicals
like ethylene and propylene.
These are the main precursors
to most of the plastic in the world.
Through electrochemistry,
we have managed to electrify already
the most energy intensive steps
on the production process
of these chemicals:
a set of processes that alone account
for a very substantial amount of energy
in the chemical manufacturing industry.
We're also rethinking the way
that we make our chemicals
and the chemicals supply chain,
by developing new processes
that can use and transform
food waste into the chemicals
that we make today from oil.
This can be done by extracting
molecules from waste streams
and using them as precursors
to things like plastics,
additives, cosmetics and pharmaceuticals,
and many more.
And in this way,
enhancing sustainability in chemical
manufacture even further.
The chemical industry is central
to our modern economy
and to our ways of life.
Decarbonizing it will take us
several decades.
This will include things like
retrofitting our chemical plants
so they can use electricity directly,
capturing and sequestering CO2
as it comes out of the gas flue stacks,
and more importantly,
developing new chemical processes
that are more efficient
and can source electricity
directly from clean sources.
By accelerating research
in electrochemical manufacturing,
my team aims to develop
some of these reactions
and in this way help to transform
the chemical industry
one reaction at a time.
When we get there,
we will have been able to erase
the carbon footprint
of the chemical industry.
And while we won't be able to bring
our tropical glaciers back,
we will have helped to develop
a sustainable path
for the future of our planet.
Thank you.
(Applause)